I enjoy baking by baking we're taking
existing materials and turning it into
something new and hopefully tasty this
is very similar to what I do in my
profession my name is Elizabeth green I
am 30 years old I come from the USA and
I am an experimental physicist I work at
the high magnetic field facility located
in Helmholtz centrum Dresden Rosa dark
we're interested in studying the
properties of materials in a variety of
extreme conditions at high magnetic
fields and low temperatures it's almost
like Christmas when you get a wrapped
present and you want to figure out
what's in that present but you can't
open it so you can shake it you can
throw it if it's not breakable
that's essentially what we do here is we
use all these instruments to figure out
what is going on inside a particular
material and what properties it exhibits
some of these materials are brand-new
and have never been studied before we
never know what we're going to encounter
we may discover a device that will
revolutionize the area of computers or
cell phones and meghna technologies just
run faster we may like higher density
storage materials we never know if we
find a room temperature superconductors
that will be a revolution we can replace
the power lines so with a superconductor
however there is no loss whatever you
put into it get out of it in the end
the high field labs is an excellent
place in my research however there are
very new facilities available like that
in the world
only a handful and a lot of this
technology that we're using we innovated
right here
we built I love to have everything
hands-on I I loved attaching samples I
love playing with the equipment I just I
can't sit still
that's terrible
it's great having my husband work here
directly next door to my laboratory
often one person will have to give up
their dreams in order to follow the
other typically when you move to a new
country but we were very very fortunate
honestly the part I loved about Germany
the best was the work-life balance our
Institute helped us find our target
speaker who's absolutely amazing I I
truly hope that the research that I do
will have a lasting impact so after I'm
gone I hope that I've made the world a
better place for my son
you